Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
new daredevil video recently charlie cox was
talking more about coming back as daredevil
and matt murdock in the mcu and what marvel
has planned for the character next as well as
talking more about coming back in spider-man no
way home there are a couple monster-sized deleted
scenes of daredevil from spider man no way home
and the bonus features so we'll talk about
those too during the video there were a bunch
of kingpin deleted scenes during hawkeye that you
probably saw as well that'll tie in with this so
i'll reference those too and if all those deleted
scenes weren't enough marvel's also releasing a
bunch of super bowl trailers this weekend i'll be
doing videos for we have a moon knight trailer and
a doctor strange multiverse of madness trailer
video so it's going to be crazy this weekend
but recently this past week you may have seen
charlie cox talking about his future as daredevil
matt murdock in the mcu he's really excited about
this he did this big fan convention where he talks
about doing more crossovers and doing more legit
daredevil episodes like a daredevil revival series
this is the clip of him talking about that i
feel so lucky to have been cast in that role
and it and it is the gift that keeps on giving
i loved every single minute of making the show
so to be honest to come back um and to
be involved in any capacity is absolutely
thrilling to me and i hope you know i don't want
to sound greedy but i hope i get to do loads more
i hope i get to be involved way way more
for many years i hope it never ends i hope
i hope it gets to the point where people are
like you're too old to be playing this part
um so look and and i i don't know what their plans
are but yes my hope is that i get to do as much as
much as i as i'm allowed to do and to be
involved and and you know be really fun the
one thing that being in the mcu allows that we
couldn't really do in the with the netflix stuff
is that i can now interact with other mcu
characters um so i'd like that would be really
cool crossovers would be really is the thing
i would like to do next i don't know what that
looks like and i don't know what you know what
they're planning and all that kind of stuff but
you know that that's there are some really
interesting stories there that i would like to
i'd love for the character to explore the funny
thing about charlie cox is that he's been like
this for the last couple of years ever since they
cancelled the daredevil netflix series and people
were theorizing that he would come into the mcu
there were rumors about it he was saying all the
same stuff like i would love to come back this is
so amazing i will play this character till i die
they'll have to force me to stop playing daredevil
but he is being a little misleading with some of
his comments in this clip he actually does know
more about where daredevil is going to appear in
the mcu next but obviously the big thing here is
that he's hyping up mcu crossovers with other big
characters and recently tom holland was also
saying that he wanted to do more spider-man
digital crossovers which would probably happen in
spider-man 4. it would be more likely that they do
that than they have spider-man show up during
a new marvel daredevil series on disney plus
currently this is how marvel has mapped out
the marvel phase 4 story arc for daredevil
with charlie cox starting with spider man no way
home and i'll also mention kingpin during this too
because a lot of what's happening with kingpin
was happening around the same time that we were
seeing daredevil so it starts in spider man no way
home the majority of that movie takes place before
hawkeye in the timeline but both of them do end
during the same christmas holiday period because
the ending scene of spider-man swinging around
in the new costume shows the christmas tree in
rockefeller center on the ice rink has not been
destroyed by hawkeye kate bishop and elena bolova
yet you have to picture the two of them running
around fighting the tracksuit bros and elena
bulova kingpin in the background while spider-man
is swinging around the city in the new suit here
don't leave eleanor come here let's talk during
spider-man no way home daredevil shows up to help
peter parker with his mysterio problem the lawsuit
damage control is trying to bring against him
happy hogan the rest of them all the spider man no
way home daredevil deleted scenes are related to
this subplot the first one is an extended version
of the interrogation scene when they're being
grilled by damage control i believe daredevil
shows up at the end of that to take their case
and to help them out then they all go back to aunt
may's old apartment together and that's when they
have the scene of him catching the brick using his
abilities telling peter he's a really good lawyer
and then tells happy hogan he will definitely
need to find himself a really good lawyer
there's also a second daredevil deleted scene
in the movie where they pay that scene off
and it's more of happy hogan with his very
good lawyer quote unquote matt murdock so
two daredevil deleted scenes the funny thing about
this is that john favreau himself was in the ben
affleck daredevil movie as that version of foggy
nelson listen this eyewitnesses say that quesada
was singled out by the demonic vigilante known as
the daredevil i don't know why you read that trash
i've been hearing stories about this guy for
years there's gonna be something to it what
like the alligators and the sewers there are
alligators in the sewers don't write my ass
about the alligators i got a friend in sanitation
okay so there's this real daredevil meta thing
going on between these two different versions of
daredevil being brought together but then after
that in the background while spider-man is busy
dealing with the multiverse problem between the
time jump at the end of the film when they're at
aunt may's grave together matt murdock wound up
helping happy avoid serious jail time then next
a little bit later in the timeline daredevil is
going to cross over in the she-hulk episodes
as another lawyer who knows jennifer walters
after she becomes she-hulk she continues to be
a lawyer defending superheroes which is also
something daredevil does they both live and work
in the new york city area by day in our vigilantes
on the side by night so it makes sense that they
would run into each other during those episodes
and reportedly daredevil will be in multiple
she-hulk episodes it won't just be a quick cameo
kingpin is not supposed to appear in she-hulk he
won't come back till the maya lopez echo series
that marvel just revealed even though the way they
played his ending very ambiguously they made you
think that she killed him at the end of hawkeye
he is not dead that moment was right out of the
comics she just winds up blinding him temporarily
with the shot sometimes family doesn't see eye
you probably saw a bunch of hawkeye kingpin
deleted scenes in your feeds recently that helped
explain more of what's going on with kingpin in
the mcu right now helped set up the maya lopez
echo series i'll do videos for all of them later
this week when they start releasing them but after
she-hulk both daredevil and kingpin are supposed
to be main characters in all those echo episodes
supposedly that series is supposed to be like an
unofficial daredevil season 4 and they'll bring
back more of the daredevil netflix characters
for that but then after the echo series marvel is
reportedly going to develop a full-blown daredevil
revival series on disney plus like we've all been
asking for like just give us a new daredevil
series or some sort of continuation of the
daredevil netflix series on disney plus by that
time they'll have already revealed what his
new mcu daredevil costumes look like multiple
costumes there are reports that marvel's gonna
put him in a version of the yellow costume
at some point during these upcoming episodes
but he won't be going back to the original
daredevil netflix version of the red costume
they're doing a totally different version of that
for the mcu probably trying to be a little bit
more comic book accurate with it too even though
i was a fan of the netflix version of the costume
they're gonna be nine she-hulk episodes and
they're supposed to come this year after the
moon night episodes i'm not expecting daredevil to
be in any of the trailers remember how we all knew
the kingpin was going to be in hawkeye elena
bulova too but they waited to show both of them in
the trailers until the last possible second it's
probably going to be the same thing with daredevil
and she-hulk issues that we're gonna get way more
of daredevil in she-hulk than we got of kingpin
in the hawkeye episodes they aren't gonna wait
to like the last two episodes of she-hulk for
him to show up for those of you asking if
the events of the daredevil netflix series
are now canon to the mcu vincent d'onofrio
said that he was playing the same version of
kingpin during the hawkeye episodes and he was
wearing the exact same cufflinks that he wore
in the daredevil netflix series those belong to
his father by the way that was the significance
of them that was why he was so obsessed with the
cufflinks here's the way that kevin feige treats
that kind of stuff every single second of every
netflix series episode for all those characters
and the expanded characters will not totally
be canon but a giant chunk of it is now canon
like some of it but not all of it like
the undertaking is probably not going
to be canon to the mcu now from the defender
series and when marvel does a new version of
iron fist in the mcu it'll probably be totally
different from what we saw in the netflix series
totally different actor totally different vibe
for the character there are rumors that kristen
ritter is going to come back as jessica
jones during she-hulk and they'll treat the
character the same way they did with daredevil and
spider-man no way home and kingpin during hawkeye
no but it's sort of like a one character at a
time situation they do this with star wars all the
time with dave filoni and john favreau plucking
stuff out of legends and making it cannon again
where is your master where is grand admiral thrawn
it is funny seeing rosario dawson after playing
night nurse in the daredevil netflix series in the
marvel universe now showing up in the live-action
star wars universe she can still come back as
night nurse just because she's in star wars
doesn't mean she can't also do future mcu stuff
i'll talk more specifically about canon timelines
for the character's backstory with avengers end
game the snap the blip when we see more footage
of them in the upcoming shows but just generally
i do not think that daredevil got snapped
mike coulter says he has not been contacted
about coming back as luke cage in any capacity
and he's doing a bunch of other tv shows
right now so it seems like he's booked up
but that doesn't mean netflix luke cage won't come
back the only character that i think they'll flat
out just reboot reimagine completely from the
ground up will be netflix iron fist during a
lot of my shongxi videos i talked about how i
think the new version of iron fist if they do
wind up doing an iron fist in the mcu at all will
come up through the shanxi sequels or will be tied
to that mythology somehow my hawkeye kingpin
deleted scenes should start posting soon make
sure you have alerts enabled for my channel so you
don't miss it and those marvel super bowl trailers
the moon knight trailer and the doctor strange
multiverse of madness trailer everyone click
here for my new spider-man multiverse video and
click here for my full moon night trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!